ragnar lothbrok may have been the star
of Vikings early seasons but his
unpredictable brother Rollo never let
him have all the glory
played by Clive Stan and Rollo is a
skilled warrior who could also be
hedonistic cruel and impulsive capable
of deep loyalty and great betrayal in
equal measure his antics caused major
trouble for his brother and drama
viewers couldn't resist Rollo was a main
player during the first four seasons of
Vikings when the plot focused heavily on
Ragnar's rise to power which Rollo beau
helped and hindered but when the History
Channel show moved on to the next
generation of Vikings the two brothers
were phased out while Ragnar met a
shudder inducing death in season four
Rollo lived to make a dramatic return in
season five during an emotional episode
that came with its own surprising
revelation Rollo was hungry for fame but
actor Clive Stanton said he was more
interested in serving the story than
racking up screen time in the lead-up to
his return on Vikings season five
Stanton told Entertainment Tonight that
he and series creator slash writer
Michael first realized that despite
their love of the character the end of
Ragnar Matt the end of rolos involvement
in the main plot Rollo's the main
antagonist of Ragnar and Ryan dragon is
gone how much should Rollo stick around
both historically and on the show Rollo
went on to become the Duke of Normandy
however Stanton also believed that role
of had unfinished business from the very
first season that needed wrapping up he
said that Johan rank who directed the
first three episodes of Vikings told him
that one of Ragnar's children was
actually Rolo's or at least that's what
Rollo suspects Stanton figured out rank
meant Bjorn the character played by
Alexander Ludwig on the current season
of Vikings so when Hirst called him with
the news that they'd found a way to fit
Rollo back into the plot of season five
Stanton was thrilled this led to the
showdown between Rollo Bjorn and
lagertha in which Rollo tries to claim
paternity over Bjorn only to be rejected
in favor of his brother yet again
I've heard something to that effect but
for truth
having played the character with this
moment in mine standin was pleased with
how it turned out saying I felt
rewarding to come back and actually
purge all that stuff that I had in the
previous seasons just as the Vikings
believed a life after death for their
heroes many TV shows never dispatched
their most beloved characters for good
fans of the show's old guard are hoping
that Rollo might make another return
during the final season of Vikings and
Hearst has dropped a confusing hint
that's giving them hope when asked by
cinema bland whether Rollo might show up
in season 6 first answered cryptically I
would say yes and no but rolos
reappearance will be a huge surprise as
indeed it was rather a surprise to me
but I'll leave it to that I don't want
to be too evasive but the answer in the
long-term is both yes and no he may be
referring to the history the show is
loosely based on although if the
showrunner is surprised by his own plots
fans have little chance of predicting
this one even if Rollo doesn't make it
back to Vikings for the final season we
may not have seen the last of the
character we already know that a
spin-off series is in the works with
Netflix Vikings ball Hollow will be set
to century after Vikings and will center
around William the Conqueror in
real-life William was the first Norman
King of England just as Rollo was the
first Viking king of Normandy that's not
the only connection between the two
series William was actually a descendant
of Rollo
even though Rollo will be long dead by
the beginning of Vikings Valhalla his
dreams of ultimate power will finally
come to fruition to his family line
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you